[Music]
this one goes out to all my gamers out
there we've all been there you know this
feeling I wake up early in the morning
making gas weep
it's like I'm in the nether cuz I can't
sleep in case you got amnesia man I want
that blue stuff I got my are a pig peg
with a for chew but I'm a white obey
because that's where it's found I'm so
frickin low keep Adam underground I got
big dreams of tearing at some big scene
hit the big leagues but you don't have
this blue but you don't have this green
but you don't have the biggest ball the
world is see ya you think I'd be
satisfied no I got the best life it's
easy to see and a hundred million people
agree because I'm mine all day all night
don't stop till the stomachs are inside
don't mind all the time but you find
what I want mind all day
I mind all night mine don't stop till
the stomachs are inside and of mine your
house I mind your mom of my my tears
till the break of dawn I think we hit
bedrock what does that mean there's
nothing deeper than feed the [ __ ] is way
too easy I swear it doesn't please me
I'm like a Reaper gleaning when I take
my chicken squeeze it and fill this
power breezing soon be 60 sheep believe
I'm bored of being at the peaks of time
to see what lies beneath what smoochie
my gamer was brewing my gamer got that
enchanted shin lapis lazuli my gamer
little [ __ ] over system II no matter
what so they can suck his dick I made
with four hundred blocks cuz I
[Music]
Pulis that time as you won't see me
crying I'm gonna stack drivers
Simon she won't see me cry bhai my
bullies I try busboy
diamonds you won't see me crying a boy
[Music]
won't see me cry me hi my bullies like
all the Harris people say the same [ __ ]
but there's no challenge in real life
it's like creative how's it feel to be
rich and have a diamond plaque [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
have you seen my diamond shag on big
slabs are big brain got a 6-pack used to
love your mining diamonds with the slope
JPEGs
remember kids life isn't fair take it
from this you won't see me probably
that diamonds boys
you see me crying oh that guy
[Music]